[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Give me
one minute, and I'll
show you how Data Studio
can put your data to work,
giving you powerful exploration
and visualization tools to tell
stories with your data.
You can think of Data Studio
as that all-in-one power
adapter that lets you charge
any device in your household.
It can take an energy, which
you can think of as data,
and then use that energy to
power any device, like reports.
Data Studio connects to
many different sources,
allowing you to quickly pull ads
data, SQL databases, BigQuery
tables and Sheets into its
processing and transformation
tools.
A strong query language,
along with useful functions,
allows you to build
metrics and dimensions
for reporting and visualizing.
When you're ready to
share your conclusions,
Data Studio is ready with
you, with graphs charts,
pivot tables, shapes, dynamic
controls for customizing
all of your data.
To get started quickly,
you can import data
from Google Ads, Analytics,
YouTube, BigQuery,
or just pull in a CSV or Sheet.
You can quickly invite others
to view or edit along with you
and embed the reports you make
inside websites, presentations,
or blog posts.
Google Data Studio is free.
This levels the business
intelligence playing field,
all fueled by the
power of Google Cloud.
So go ahead, unite
all your data sources,
explore, and transform,
tell impactful stories
that help illuminate
trends, and next time you're
looking to do data analysis
for business intelligence,
take a minute to
look at Data Studio.
To learn more, check out
datastudio.google.com.
[MUSIC PLAYING]